foreign
[Applause]
it's a chant echoed across continents
but here in the predominantly black
continent of Africa it takes on more
significance
these migrants were rounded up by
tunigian security forces in the city of
svax and brought here last week
this is a largely desert area on the
Libyan border with no access to health
care or any type of humanitarian support
Human Rights Watch has accused the
Tunisian government of collective
expulsion of black migrants sini kamada
has been here for seven days she says
she's seven months pregnant
even the nights they've gone Beatles and
beats me now I'm I'm seeing on my period
now
I'm very stressed
they are calling this area 0.0 stranded
in this 10 meter buffer zone between
Tunisia and Libya these migrants
including pregnant women and children
say no one has heard their cries
David says his two-year-old son is still
in swax hero and every country has a law
it has the logistics and it has a U.N
and immigration so if they don't work us
there's no need for them to bring us
here they are supposed to take us to the
U.N or to the immigration or take us
back to our countries now there is at
least two locations that we know of
where migrants remain stranded on the
Tunisian and Libyan border there's this
place on the coast but a few kilometers
to the South there's another area in the
middle of the desert
they take refuge from the Sun under
these trees they say while Tunisian
authorities transferred hundreds of
migrants away from the border to the
areas of tatawin and madanine their bus
turned around and dumped them here
this man faints from the scorching Sun
they give him what little water they
have every single drop they've become a
family here
says his brother Musa died two days ago
his body remains in the Desert Sun a few
hundred meters away we are dying one
after the water my brother is gone it
might be me today it might be another
person please we are begging you people
save us from this Daddy please
there are still hundreds of migrants who
were expelled from zwax Stranded along
the Tunisian and Libyan border their
fate is unknown and their condition as
desperate as ever the ones here say if
nothing is done soon they'll die here
Malik trainer Al Jazeera on the Tunisian
Libyan border